Um, I had a a piece up there this
morning about uh the Orthodox,
Russia and the Orthodox Christian
Byzantine, and then the the Western
Church. Maybe we could come together to
fight uh the Islamist, the secularists,
the atheist, the Marxist, the
transhumanist. It's quite a collection
of of enemies. The ancient enemy since I
guess 6 or 700 has been Islam. Uh first
off, how are the books how are the books
uh how are the books doing Raymond?
>> They're doing very really well. I've uh
been mon the best I can do is look at
Amazon and um more or less if you look
at especially early Christian history
they pretty much dominate the first
three the three bestselling spots. So
last I looked two two swords of Christ
was number one. I think Defenders was
number two and uh okay yeah that's
probably the most recent one and and
Sword of Scimitar is number four. Um but
they keep fluctuating but Two Swords of
Christ has been at number one since
basically came actually before it came
out which is great.
>> Uh I think you know the appeal of the
two swords of Christ is you're just it's
not just the history but it's the uh an
explanation of the theological
underpinning of Christian militancy
which I think is a very important topic
that um a lot of people prefer not to.
Tell tell me about it because because
you would think today monks you know you
hear about um uh St. Francis of Aisi and
you hear about this really these passive
very powerful spiritual warriors but it
wasn't the church militant. Tell me
about today because you have a rise this
particularly this younger generation of
men that uh are saying hey look I'm a
Christian but I'm not going to be
passive about it. I'm going to be
militant about it. What do these two
monastic orders tell us about that, sir?
>> Sure. And I'll just start off by saying
even people like Francis of Aisi who are
so widely seen as being passive, he was
actually fully on board with the
crusades. Um, and I talk a little bit
about it in the two swords of Christ
because he he figures in there. And his
goals was one of the main goals was
actually instead of killing and fighting
with Muslims, let's try to convert them.
and you know he risked his life on
numerous occasions but he was fully on
board with the idea of a of a military
order and a monk who fights war and um
so I think the issue you know Steve I've
been giving this much thought but the
what's going on now I think with western
Christianity and I think this is the
inherent problem is that no matter what
Christians say they're all in the end
despite themselves they're materialists
and what I mean by that is um they've
lost the the metaphysical understanding
of of theology and morality ity and so
everything is distilled in a materialist
point of view just like an atheist which
is which is my way of saying that they
think all that you know what is good and
evil is based on the material therefore
the worst thing a Christian can do is
physically hurt someone because it's the
material we acknowledge that but things
like morality uh they because they're
metaphysical and uh they've become this
is why you have all these Christians
saying oh you know don't judge oh you
know love is love and all that sort of
thing so I think uh when when you look
at the world through a materialist lens
like a lot of Christians do. Violence
and killing become the absolute greatest
sin. That's not how earlier Christians
seen it because they actually were
Christians and they actually accepted in
the metaphysical that which is beyond
the physical as even more important.
Okay? So things like morality was much
more important than physical harm. Um so
I think that's why one of the reasons
modern day Christians can't understand
how can you fight back, how can you
kill, etc. But when you look in the book
and you see the the logic and the
rationale by people like St. Bernard of
Clairvo uh and they quote it and it's
all scriptural too and that's the point.
This isn't made up. We can go back and
the title of the book the two swords of
Christ was a pivotal theme that goes
back to the verse in Luke where Christ
says you know uh sell your garment buy a
sword and they say look Lord here are
two swords and he says that's enough. So
how that was understood then was that
Christ was saying one sword against
spiritual evil which modern day
Christians I think still understand but
also a secular sword against physical
evil uh to protect the innocent to
protect the poor to protect the orphan
and the widow. Okay. Uh so that was
actually seen as a good thing and there
and as you know there's so much we can
talk about just war theory that's
completely embedded both old new
testament. Okay. So no one back then had
a problem. But I think today as you were
saying one of the big issu big issues is
you know this sort of passivity turn the
other cheek which I call dormat
Christianity has been so popularized
that every Christian thinks this is real
Christianity. This is the only form of
Christianity which is for me to do
nothing but to be a doormat. I can never
ever judge. I can never say this is
wrong behavior. I just have to shut up
and take it. And that I mean that is the
greatest blue. If I'm an enemy of
Christianity, that's the smartest thing
I could get Christians to believe. Okay.
Um, and they are. And a lot of, as you
were also indicating, a lot of young men
find this distasteful. And it's not,
it's I always hear, you know, uh,
churches, men are leaving churches.
Well, there's a reason because the
message that's actually this message,
this doormat Christianity doesn't
resonate with our nature, which God gave
us, uh, which is to defend, you know,
uh, to defend the innocent and the
victims and the and the poor and fight
back. So this sort of emasculation of
Christianity which completely works in
tandem with the enemy uh who and I speak
in the abstract of course um I think
that's all by design. It's all
intentional. It has no res it doesn't
resonate with historical Christianity.
Of course there was mercy and love and
forgiveness and I'm not talking about
that. But I'm talking on a social order
level. Okay? There has to be justice.
There has to be retribution there and
and violence is not the do is not the
endall. Okay? Okay. So, Christians need
to understand that the number one
commandment is not that you won't
physically hurt someone. Morality was
much more important. Okay. Uh and
preserving morality than physically
harming someone. So, I think uh
Christians need to get over being so
materialists like atheists.